the other controversy I heard was
yesterday you really had a blowout with
Mike Pearl oh no no [__] man
you try to embarrass me in the worst
[__] way yesterday what happened he
takes me to Muscle Beach right like the
real deal right guys lifting 400 [__]
pounds and [__] bench pressing that the
[__] dumbbells that like 50 pound
dumbbells right first it starts we're
leaving the hotel we're supposed to be
getting in an Uber car going to the
beach right then he comes up with the
scheme oh we could ride bicycles there
okay I'm not riding down [__] Collins
Avenue on a [__] bicycle right sorry
I'm not getting killed for [__] Mike
Perlman right then we get to the [__]
place and he comes out with his with his
muscles shirt on and his tight [__]
black shorts on why don't you bring me
and he's got he's got the [__] back
belt you know for support lifting Danny
and he's walking down the street like
the you know like Muscle Man Charlie
here yeah so we get there
[__] guys man they're all the arms
are out to here and they look like the
Rock and he's taking me over there right
in the middle of everybody and he's
going yeah we're gonna work out now yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna set the bars you
know we're just gonna warm up a little
bit I do [__] you that was just
embarrassing to you I would be
embarrassed as [__] you know and then
without his monkey we're having this
whole argument there and like
everybody's looking at us and [__] like
just what he wanted I wasn't trying
to listen well we got to do something so
he takes me over to the [__] swings
the little kids swings and puts me in
the [__] swinging
right I did it yeah I did that no
problem power this was all night this is
this was our dinner last night all night
I thought the waiter was gonna shoot
himself this was all now you guys are
like uh oil and water you know because
he tries to [__] bug my ass all the
time Ronnie did lift a little bit though
I had him lift the barbell he did one
one uh no I didn't do one
I spotted him he didn't put any weights
on no you didn't spot me because they
didn't get the [__] away from me
he wouldn't let him spot you no
what happened with the dessert last
night you were at the restaurant dude
what happened you got to hear this
[__] this guy's office veraca I don't
know who he thinks he is really right
the guy was nice and to bring over this
nice dessert I go you know when I get
anything you want some of this mic take
you don't want to take some he goes real
men don't order dessert unless they're
on a date
really yeah what's that about I have no
[__] clue that I never heard dessert
something you get an espresso you get a
coffee you don't get he's sitting there
he's eating a chocolate cake
and then it had a strawberry on top
[Music]
like a little kid eating his chocolate
cake
do you know how stupid you sound saying
this [__] about dessert so he just
didn't didn't fit him he's sitting there
and he's like eating and he's all happy
and he's eating his his chocolate cake
he's a whipped cream and his little
strawberry on top you think I'm the guy
who's trying to be Italian listen to the
[__] dude
he's going off with that too you know
the truth dude you're projecting though
I think you're projecting on me a little
bit
what happened literally anything Mike
Perlman says completely sets Ronnie off
even if it's just innocent comment
because like
Perlman said uh doesn't your didn't your
father work at the the Garment District
and Ronnie's like what the [__] are you
talking about like
he's talking about his family and his
father you know what it is Mike you've
set him off so many times now he's just
crazy from you he really he thinks he
knows everything in my [__] head yeah
he's because I think his he's obsessed
yeah he's become very focused
[Laughter]
foreign